[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous mercredi avec 14 mars
bienvenue dans le 7-8 journal sur tv 78
l'essentiel de l'actualité locale et
régionale tout de suite les titres de
cette édition la bataille d'une poignée
de riverains saint cyr l'école depuis
presque deux mois ses habitants du
quartier renard réunis en collectif sont
en conflit avec la mairie un motif la
diminution de places de stationnement
suite à des travaux de voirie dans la
ville il demande notamment la mise en
place d'une place pour les personnes
handicapées reportage dans ce journal
coup de projecteur sur un duo l'athlète
malvoyants raphaël bougie n'est yanji
jarrier du club de vélizy 78 en tandem
il participe la semaine prochaine aux
mondiaux de cyclisme sur piste
handisport c'est un rio au brésil nous
avons suivi leur préparation au
vélodrome national de saint quentin en
yvelines
et puis découverte d'une activité
sportive et de loisirs le ball-trap est
un exercice de tir mêlant réflexes et
adresse dans la forêt de rambouillet est
l'un des plus vieux clubs de france se
réunit chaque week-end pour pratiquer la
discipline
à suivre également dans ce journal un
invité pascale beaudin membres engagés
denner city 78 à l'association a en
projet la création d'une coopérative
citoyenne de panneaux photovoltaïques on
en parle tout à l'heure dans le journal
c'est un conflit qui dure depuis presque
2 ans de 2 mois à saint-cyr-l'ecole
pardon entre la mairie et un collectif
de riverains du quartier renard suite à
la mise en place d'une un double sens
dans une avenue ses habitants elles ne
peuvent plus et garé leur voiture le
long du trottoir une interdiction qui a
du mal à pat a passé comme vous allez le
voir avec ce reportage d'aurélie rose
voici la rue au coeur de la polémique
fin janvier plusieurs riverains qui
avaient garé leur voiture dans cette
avenue ont découvert une contravention
de 135 euros sur leur pare-brise donc la
fameuse petite contraventions qui
indique pas du tout
pourquoi comment la date l'heure au
début de l'année la voie était en sens
unique mais en raison des travaux qui
ont pris de l'ampleur dans le quartier
renard la municipalité a décidé de
passer la ksa double sens et d'interdire
le stationnement hors des emplacements
matérialisés
la raison qui nous est donné c'est oui
il faut que les engins puissent circuler
dans cette avenue mais ce soir à double
sens où que ce soit à sens unique qu'on
soit garée d'un côté ça me change rien
ça il ya toujours une place pour que les
camions passent comme nous avons des
personnes âgées qui viennent parce que
je suis retraité et qu'ils n'ont pas de
place dans la rue et bien plutôt que
d'aller très très loin il préfère s'en
aller carrément et nous préviennent que
ne viendront pas ce jour là quoi
pointant le manque de place dans le
quartier les riverains demandent au
maire de les autoriser à pouvoir
stationner de nouveau dans cette avenue
réponse de l'intéressé de nombreuses
places payantes dans le parking
souterrain de la résidence sont
disponibles la ville a exigé dès le
départ de la part des constructeurs qui
est 25 à 30 % de places de plus que le
nombre de logements
malheureusement aujourd'hui des gens qui
ont des voitures dans les villes il y
aura toujours un problème de
stationnement en surface on ne pourra
pas avoir autant de places qui lie à
bois tueur autre requête du collectif de
riverains une place pour les personnes
handicapées la mairie répond qu'il
suffit d'en faire simplement la demande
le congrès départemental de la cgt des
yvelines se tient jusqu'à demain jeudi
aux mureaux 200 militants font le bilan
sur les actions menées sur le territoire
il dresse également les prochains
combats sociaux notamment sur la réforme
ferroviaire ce mercredi matin ça a été
confirmé en conseil des ministres cette
réforme se fera par ordonnance la future
loi devrait ouvrir le rail français à la
concurrence
elle mettra fin également au statut de
cheminot al embauche la cgtl de son côté
prépare sa mobilisation nicolas landry a
rencontré hier philippe martinez il est
le secrétaire général du syndicat il
était présent donc aux mureaux pour ce
congrès départemental
fipar thinès vous avez rencontré hier le
premier ministre pour présenter des
propositions de la cgt concernant la
réforme ferroviaire donc votre vision de
cette réforme
est-ce que vous pouvez nous détailler
ses propositions assez les détails et
c'est difficile parce que c'est un
rapport de 70 pages mais globalement
nous avons mis l'accent sur le besoin
d'investissements et donc ce que propose
le gouvernement qui peut paraître une
somme importante
puisque ça tourne autour de semble-t-il
autour d'une trentaine de milliards
c est ce qu a investi tous les ans la
sncf donc il faut une que l'état mette
plus pour permettre que les trains
circulent la deuxième chose importante
c'est de doubler les capacités du fret
puisque le gouvernant on n'en parle pas
le fret c'est le transport de
marchandises c'est écologique
ça fait moins d'embouteillages parce que
ça permet de mettre des marchandises sur
les voies et puis ça peut permettre de
mieux utiliser les voies parce que quand
il n'y a que des trains de voyageurs sur
les voies
ça peut paraître insuffisant alors que
si on double avec des trains de
marchandises y compris de réouvrir ou
d'allonger des lignes je pense dans un
département comme celui ci où il reste
des industries et bien ça peut permettre
et de faire venir les salariés au boulot
est de faire venir les marchandises
nous avons nous avons rappelé aussi que
le statut n'était pas un problème pour
la sncf puisque c'est pas le statut qui
cause les retards les statuts qui
empêche les train de partir nous avons
aussi insisté sur le besoin d'embauchés
à la sncf
lorsque vous le savez notamment en
ile-de-france et une pénurie de
conducteurs mais il ya aussi une pénurie
de savoir faire et donc il ya besoin de
ré internaliser des activités à sncf
il s'agit pas de dire que les salariés
du privé ne savent pas travailler
par contre leurs patrons on vise les
bénéfices et non pas le service aux
usagers voilà résumé c'est ses
propositions phares que nous avons
proposé au premier ministre le
gouvernement semble prendre un autre
chemin une voie vers l'ouverture de la
concurrence
vers la privatisation de la sncf par
rapport à la méthode aussi caisse quel
regard vous portez sur ces propositions
du ces
premièrement les mesures nous les
contestions rien n'oblige le
gouvernement français à ouvrir
un service public à la concurrence ça
c'est d'ailleurs dans de nombreux pays
des gouvernements l'ont pas fait si on
considère que c'est d'utilité publique
il ya possibilité de déroger ça c'est la
première chose ensuite
le gouvernement veut essayer d'aller
vite
comme il le fait à chaque fois serre
qu'il confie ce que le débat aux
citoyens nous nous voulons que les
usagers ils prennent la parole oui
pourquoi certains écoliers disent je ne
prends plus le train parce qu'on a
changé les horreurs et si je prends ce
train là je vais arriver en retard à
l'école mais qu'il le dise et donc
construire avec les usagers les besoins
dont ils ont 2 dont ils nécessitent je
parlais des écoliers mais on peut parler
des salariés et donc à les faire passer
cette loi par ordonnance s'est coupé
court au débat et c'est une volonté de
passer en force mais je crois que c'est
une méthode maintenant traditionnel du
gouvernement
autre question c'est le 20ème congrès de
l'union départementale de la cgt des
yvelines
en quoi c'est important pour le
secrétaire général de la cgt d'être
présent à ce genre d'événement il me
semble que pour le secrétaire général de
la cgt mais pour l'ensemble des
dirigeants c'est important d'aller au
contact des syndiqués mais aussi des
salariés
si c'est un congrès dont il ya que des
syndiqués mais j'aime aller
régulièrement dans les entreprises
discuter avec les salariés pourquoi
parce que quand on veut parler de la
réalité du travail ou de ceux qui n'en
n'ont pas si on discute pas avec eux si
on ne les écoute pas comment parler et
c'est de mon point de vue ce qui manque
à un certain nombre de ministres ils
décrivent la vraie vie enfin leur vraie
vie qui ne correspond pas à celle de la
très grande majorité des citoyens et
quel regard vous portez sur cette union
départementale de la cgt
c'est une union départementale dynamique
dans un département qui est compliqué
compliqué parce que il ya des zones
d'activités très importante
il ya une profonde mutation du salariat
mai et puis il ya des zones
je dirais un peu plus rurales et donc il
ya besoin que
la cgt elle soit présente dans ces zones
où il ya une forte activité avec une
mutation du salariat aussi parce que je
travaille au technocentre de renault et
on voit bien que c'est à une quasi
unanimité d ingénieur cadre technicien
donc comment prend en compte ces
catégories nous avons des propositions
nous avons des revendications
donc voilà c'est toute la diversité du
département qui est complexe
en tout cas il ya une dynamique et je
sens dans les débats que la dynamique
elle est vraiment là dans les débats il
ya un sujet qui est revenu notamment
certains membres de la cgt des yvelines
ne ressentent une certaine déception par
rapport aux mobilisations sur les
ordonnances quelle quelle est votre
analyse est ce que c'est vraiment une
déception pour la cgt la mobilisation de
l'an dernier à ccc c'est une déception
parce qu'on n'a pas réussi à empêcher le
gouvernement d'appliquer les
gouvernements successifs de d'amputer de
nouveau le droit des droits collectifs
et le code du travail
en même temps tout le monde s'est
accordé à dire qu'il y avait une très
forte mobilisation n'a été face à des
gouvernements successifs qui parle
beaucoup de dialogue social mais qui
n'écoute pas ce qu'ils se manifestent et
ceux qui soutiennent les manifestations
mais en même temps c'est aussi un bilan
tu nous tirons qui a besoin ce que je
disais tout à l'heure d'être encore au
plus près des salariés parce que c'est
pas facile
nous le savons c'est pas facile de déjà
signé une pétition quand on est
intérimaire quand on est contractuel et
que on travaille de façon épisodique on
en est bien conscient et donc il faut
que dans notre démarche syndicale
eh bien on prenne pas en compte et
écouter aussi les salariés de la façon
dont ils veulent s'exprimer
afficher leur mécontement north
mécontentement donc j'allais dire on a
tout l'avenir devant nous si on est
toujours plus près des réalités du monde
du travail éducation emmanuel macron a
laissé le choix aux communes rester à la
semaine de quatre jours et demi ou
revenir aux quatre jours si beaucoup de
villes ont déjà opté pour l'une ou
l'autre des formules attrape veut un
entre-deux maintenir les quatre jours et
demi dans les écoles primaires mais
proposer une semaine de quatre jours en
maternelle est la ville a fait une
demande
dérogation à l'éducation nationale
solutions avancées pour faciliter
l'organisation des parents mais aussi
pallier l'état de fatigue à des enfants
maternelle une volonté qui ne fait pas
l'unanimité des associations de parents
d'élèves s'y opposer un collectif de
sang neuf enseignants a d'ores et déjà
envoyé un courrier au ministre de
l'éducation nationale
j'accueille sur ce plateau en invités
c'est pascale beaudin bonsoir bonsoir
vous êtes membres engagés de
l'association inner city 78 alors lundi
vous avez tenu votre assemblée générale
ça se tenait à la maison des
associations de versailles
l'occasion de faire le point sur votre
projet le projet c'est de créer une
coopérative citoyenne de panneaux
photovoltaïques on va en parler dans un
instant déjà un mois ou deux sur sur
l'association nerfs city 78 quelle est
son histoire et et quelles sont ses buts
à cette association
alors l'histoire c'est une association
qui a mené des actions concrètes qui ont
été réalisés sous l'impulsion du
festival les alternatives en 2015 à la
verrière la coursive al des alternatives
qu'on appelle festival alternatiba et à
la création de cette association on
était prêt à lancer un projet rentable
mais qui a pas pu déboucher parce que le
prix de rachat d'électricité a baissé
continuellement depuis et donc on a eu
du mal à obtenir la rentabilité du
projet et aujourd'hui on va donner de
nouveaux éléments
donc on va avoir l'occasion de parler de
ce projet du coup l'idée de
l'association l'objectif de la mission
de l'association c'est d'être un
incubateur de projets d'énergie
renouvelable
et c'est un des projets qui sont des
projets citoyens alors les trois mois je
veux les détails et un petit peu
l'incubateur ça veut bien dire que le
but du jeu c'est de créer les conditions
favorables à la naissance de coopérative
photovoltaïque énergie renouvelable
c'est notre engagement énergies
décarbonées et citoyens parce qu'on
pense qu'il est important que les
citoyens se réapproprient leurs
ressources énergétiques les ressources
énergétiques du territoire le solaire en
fait partie et que ce soit les citoyens
qui se le réapproprient nous semble
important vous parlez des énergies
renouvelables cette thématique pourquoi
le revêt aujourd'hui une importance
capitale
vous avez tout le monde connaît
la coop 21 et le plan qui consiste à
limiter le réchauffement climatique en
dessous de deux degrés ce que je vous
propose cette détaillants très
rapidement pourquoi ça nous concerne du
point de vue d'un point de vue national
et puis régional donc la coop 21 donne
lieu à une engagements de production
d'énergies décarbonées qui est essentiel
qui veut dire au niveau national que 23%
des énergies doivent être renouvelable
en 2020 en 2016
on n'a atteint que 70% de l'objectif
donc on n'est pas en trajectoire pour le
faire avec des trajectoires conservative
donc il faut essayer de se bouger pour
le faire
en ile de france on est à 2 % seulement
des énergies renouvelables voilà donc
oui les choses sont encore à faire et
chaussures sur ce sujet alors pour
présenter on a parlé de ce projet de
coopérative citoyenne sur le
photovoltaïque
quel est l'objectif quel est l'objectif
finalement d'une telle coopérative 1
l'objectif d'une telle coopérative
passer de ces de produire de
l'électricité
renouvelable à partir de photovoltaïque
on se concentre sur le photovoltaïque
parce que c'est la ressource qui nous
semble la plus facile à mettre en oeuvre
aujourd'hui en ile-de-france oreilles
même s'il y en a d'autres et donc voilà
le l'idée c'est de lancer des
coopératives d'énergie renouvelable avec
les citoyens et comment fonctionnera
intel coopérative alors déjà
l'association son idée c'est d'aller de
prospecter pour trouver des toits
disponible donc en particulier auprès
des particuliers mais aussi auprès des
auprès des communes de recenser les
toits disponibles et à partir de toits
disponible de proposer l'idée d'aider
les équipes et ça veut dire chercher un
installateur trouve un installateur
réunir les personnes qui souhaitent
financer le projet crée avec ces
personnes la coopérative est lancé et
fait réaliser le projet de production
d'énergie renouvelable à partir de
photovoltaïque
donc une fois que s'est lancé l'idée
c'est de produire ces énergies de les
revendre à 2 les retrouve andral un
tarif négocié à edf très bien et ensuite
c'est il ya une redistribution des
sommes perçues c'est ça qu'ils arrivent
au sein de la coopérative de fait au
sein de la coopérative pour les
sociétaires qui ont participé à l'
investissement sur la coopérative
alors où en est le projet aujourd'hui
vous avez dit pendant quelques mois
c'est un projet qui a été freinée mais
la donne a changé puisque en
ile-de-france le photovoltaïque a
maintenant une place importante il ya
une subvention qui a été votée sur le
photovoltaïque
alors voilà donc on était confronté à un
problème d'équilibré de rentabilité est
aujourd'hui vu justement que les
trajectoires pour atteindre les
objectifs donc la feuille de route de la
région sont difficiles à atteindre la
région en a pris conscience et avec un
certain nombre d'acteurs qui sont en
fait des petits frères et des petites
soeurs ou des frères et soeurs de nerfs
city 78 à d'autres endroits de la région
ile de france
on a eu des échanges avec la région et
la région aujourd'hui prévoit de
débloquer un budget de 2 2 millions
d'euros sur 2018 2019 pour aider à
financer des projets citoyens
photovoltaïque est donc ce qui permettra
d'atteindre le niveau d'autant mieux
rentabilité
pour ces projets on précise parce que le
temps file qui a des contacts de votre
association aujourd'hui avec les
communes de voisins-le-bretonneux avec
le pnr également dû de la haute vallée
de chevreuse et des projets similaires
de coopérative qui sont nés dans le sud
de la france où on sait le
l'ensoleillement est plus conséquent
casson une idée reçue le photovoltaïque
en ile de france
est ce qu'on peut faire du
photovoltaïque efficace en ile-de-france
en fait non on peut parfaitement faire
de manière efficace en ile-de-france ont
ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que le il ya
une mesure technique qui permet de
savoir ça qu'ils aient le temps de
retour énergétique c'est-à-dire le temps
de production qui permet de compenser
l'énergie dépensés pendant la
fabrication et ce temps de retour pour
les panneaux photovoltaïques il est de 5
ans pour des installations qui sont
prévus pour plus de 25 ans voire 30
donc il est parfaitement possible de
faire du photovoltaïque en ile-de-france
à derniers mois sur l'assemblée générale
de lundi ce que beaucoup de personnes
sont intéressées par ce projet écoutez
il y avait 40 personnes qui étaient
présentes
à l'âge et il y en a trente trois qui
ont pris leur adhésion 2018 à l'occasion
de l'ag
l'ag s'est faite en présence donc
effectivement de une élue de la verrière
qui est chargé du développement durable
et de la démocratie locale et en
présence d'une chargé de mission du pnr
de chevroches de chevreuse donc oui il
ya de la motivation et on peut retrouver
plus d'informations en tout cas sur ce
projet sur le site des nerfs city 78
avec qui s'affiche en bas de l'écran
merci pascale beaudin d'abord été avec
nous il s'est beaucoup nous rappelle
membres engagés de cette association
nerfs city 78 c'est une tradition depuis
plus de 20 ans guyancourt mais deux fois
par an ces diplômes du travail
récompenses aux habitants pour le nombre
d'années travaillées
une cérémonie se déroulait vendredi
dernier à l'hôtel de ville
une dizaine de personnes distinguées
certains ont reçu un grand or pour 40
années de travail propos recueillis sur
place par nicolas landry
ça permet de mettre en avant
l'investissement professionnel de
nombreux habitants à guyancourt on a une
dynamique
économiques très importantes à
l'attractivité du territoire
puisqu'on a un nombre important
d'entreprises qui se sont installés sur
guyancourt et qui sont effectivement
créatrice d'emplois et cette ressource
économique et est importante pour une
ville comme la nôtre comme pour les
vides puisque ça permet d'offrir un
service public de qualité aux habitants
et nous vous proposerons prochainement
un portrait sur l'un de ses aiguilles en
cours 3 gluant courtois récompensé par
la ville un sport à présent dans cette
édition les championnats du monde de
cyclisme sur piste handisport débute la
semaine prochaine les mondiaux se
déroulent cette année à rio au brésil
sur l'ancien tracé à des jeux
paralympiques de 2016 et à la proche de
cette compétition est les pistards
français sont venus s'entraîner au
vélodrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines parmi eux
l'athlète malvoyants raphaël beau gilet
y sera en tandem avec yann dujarrier du
club de vélizy 78 est michael et demi
d'euros les a rencontrés depuis
plusieurs jours ce tandem enchaîne les
tours de piste sur le vélodrome national
de saint quentin en yvelines
raphaël bougies athlètes touchées par un
handicap visuel eliane dujarrier du club
de vélizy 78 doivent peaufiner les
derniers détails avant de s'envoler pour
les championnats du monde handisport
programmée au brésil les 22 et 23 mars
pour l'instant ça fonctionne plutôt pas
mal après faut encore qu'on apprenne à
se connaître c'est comme un bas comme un
couple est plus là bas ya le côté
sportif faut qu'on se règlent bas sur
les braquer et tout ce qui va avec
pédaler à deux dans le même sens une
nouvelle expérience pour hygiène
dujarrier ce sportif yves binois de 41
ans vice champion du monde masters s'est
associé à ce projet avec l'équipe de
france depuis le mois de janvier
c'est très valorisant pour moi de me
dire que ben voila je peux être
accompagné quelqu'un et aider quelqu'un
à réaliser ses objectifs et a réalisé
des choses qu'il n'aurait pas pu faire
si l'ipad avec moi comme je vais à
l'entraînement aux entraînements que je
peux faire tout seul je les fais plus de
la même manière c'est vrai que je
m'entraîne pour lui je m'entraîne plus
pour moi et ça c'est autre chose
après une première expérience en
championnat de france handisport en
janvier couronné par une qualification
mondiaux les deux athlètes espère
désormais passer un cap au niveau des
résultats et s'aligneront sur la vitesse
et le kilomètre on espère pouvoir entrer
dans les dix
qui nous permettrait de marquer des
points au niveau au niveau mondial et
ensuite il faudrait qu'on passe dans les
huit premiers pour pouvoir accéder au
tournoi final
et là ce serait la cerise sur le gâteau
il premières échéances internationales
avant de viser le graal pour une athlète
handisport les jeux paralympiques de
tokyo en 2020 il ya 80 ans se déroule l
exposition universelle à paris la
dernière accueillis par la capitale à
l'université versailles saint quentin en
yvelines propose depuis quelques jours
de redécouvrir de la redécouvrir cette
exposition à travers des clichés des
objets pour la plupart inédits le
reportage de nickel et demi d'euros et
wilfrid richy la 1937 la capitale
accueille l'exposition internationale
des arts et des techniques appliquées à
la vie moderne
deux ans avant que n'éclate le second
conflit mondial 45 nations de
l'allemagne nazie à l'italie fasciste en
passant par l'urss s'y retrouve
ce qui fait aussi la particularité de
cette exposition c'est qu'elle allie le
beau et la technique donc il ya des
pavillons emblématique et des employés y
ont aussi qu'ils resteront notamment le
palais de tokyo et un des palais que
derrière nous également le palais du
trocadéro au sein de la bibliothèque
universitaire à guyancourt les visiteurs
peuvent découvrir des clichés inédits
réalisés par l'architecte paysagiste
achille duchêne et conservées jusque là
par son arrière petit-fils du jeu d
acteur principal de l'expulsion de 37
ans plus une photographie il est le
responsable
l'exposition et photographiques depuis
chez lui où il était de relations de
saint paul il photographie de
l'évolution devant le palais de tokyo
doit tous les bâtiments de l'expulsion
de 37 ans qu'il a un rôle prépondérant
on voit rarement exposé de septembre on
voit l'expo terminer avec ces pavillons
mais là on voit l'exploit en train de se
faire alors évidemment on n'a pas plu
tout reproduire on a laissé quelques
clichés originaux on a évidemment
reproduit sur des grands panneaux
quelques photos qui nous semblait tout à
fait emblématique mais évidemment après
il ya d'autres aspects que nous abordons
par ailleurs un angle d'approché rare
qui permet aux étudiants et au grand
public d'aborder à la fois l'aspect
culturel mais aussi politique alors que
la france vient de retirer sa
candidature pour l'exposition
universelle de 2025 le public peut donc
redécouvrir celle de 1937
la dernière organisée sur notre
territoire et qui entendait promouvoir
la paix acrobates rois mages ours depuis
le 10 mars et la 8e édition de la
biennale de la sculpture à voisins le
bretonneux
l événement se tient jusqu'au 25 mars
près de 100 oeuvres sont exposées à la
maison aux deux coville zoom avec
mélanie poker
[Musique]
une certaine douceur qui mène à la
contemplation une acrobate suspendu qui
regarde un ours en équilibre pour sa
huitième édition voisins le bretonneux a
sélectionné 47 artistes venus de toute
la france
c'est une biennale qui est ouverte à
tout le monde en fait n'est pas de ce
n'est pas réservé aux visites mois nous
avons souhaité l'ouvrir justement il ya
quelques années pour pouvoir avoir un
plus grand nombre d'oeuvres une plus
grande variété une certaine émulation
[Musique]
tous les styles toutes les techniques du
textile au bronze plus d'une centaine d'
inventions exposé à la maison de covile
c'est beaucoup plus simple d'aller vers
des expos de peinture il y en a à peu
près partout
la sculpture c'est un art nettement plus
méconnu donc le fait de faire une
biennale de faire venir à voisin
quantité une quantité d'artistes variés
impressionnante
voilà c'est bien parce que les gens vont
vous découvrir des choses qui
généralement n'ont pas l'occasion
d'aller voir
un public qui pourra aussi faire
connaître son coup de coeur un prix sera
remis le 25 mars
la biennale reviendra dans deux ans
[Musique]
pour refermer ce journal découverte du
ball-trap c'est le tir sportif
consistant à abattre au fusil des cibles
appelé la tour dans les yvelines la
discipline peut s'exercer au sein d'une
des plus vieilles associations du genre
en france le club
ball-trap rambolitains les adhérents se
réunissent tous les week-ends à la forêt
de rambouillet les images sont signés
patrick jacques de dixmude paul réflexe
adresse précision le ball-trap mêle
plusieurs compétences cette activité de
tir sportif est pratiqué par 150 à 200
personnes à l'année chaque week-end en
forêt de rambouillet et deux disciplines
sont proposées au sein du ball-trap
rambolitains ont fait que des
disciplines qui ne sont pas olympique
donc ici ces parcours de chasse et
compact sporting
alors ces deux disciplines différentes
il y en a ici vous êtes sur une surface
d'à peu près 100 m² avec plusieurs
postes avec un menu dvd fils défilant et
à la fin vous avez tiré 25 plateaux et
vous avez le compact sporting
là où vous savez les gens sont les uns à
côté des autres car chacun cinq plateaux
sur chaque poste et après échange de
postes sur sa position le tireur choisi
son plateau ils sont différents les
trajectoires peuvent être tendues ou
encore en parabole le plateau peut être
également roule en imitant le
déplacement au sol d'un lapin une fois
en place il n'y a plus qu'à actionner
cette télécommande
donc ça c'est une télécommande qui
permet d'envoyer les plateaux et de
suivre les menus que vous avez les
lettres ici sur le menu à l'alcool et à
la lettre à quand la personne est prête
et appelle le plateau à on appuie sur le
bouton a et le plateau 120 hommes
longtemps prisé par les seuls chasseurs
le ball-trap s'ouvre peu à peu de
nouveaux pratiquants se lance comme
anaïs inscrits au club depuis l'été 2010
est elle souhaite s'entraîner avant de
se tourner vers quelques compétitions à
ce qui me plaît c'est que c'est ça
demande beaucoup de concentration que ça
défoule on sort de là on a la tête vidée
et et on se sent bien c'est
c'est un sport qui est assez congrès
fait deux trois ans où on sent qu'il ya
de plus en plus de monde qui vient pas
alors nous dans un cadre très peu cadre
qui fait que les gens viennent chez nous
investi énormément tous les ans en
investissant dans la cabane et c'est
donc c'est du bouche à oreille et les
gens aiment bien venir ici
vous pratiquez le ball-trap est tout de
même onéreux compte et 1500 euros pour
vous équiper d'un fusil performant c'est
la fin de ce journal merci de l'avoir
suivi très bonne soirée à tous sur tv 78
[Musique]